so Texas Senator Ted Cruz this week
writing to DHS secretary mayorcas he
wants more information about the
screening process of migrants who enter
the country using the Customs and Border
Protection One app and are looking to
board flights Cruz wants to know why the
TSA is even letting illegal immigrants
in without identification to use the app
to get on a plane he says that process
quote takes illegal aliens at their word
Congressman chip Roy Republic
of Texas joins me now thank you so much
for talking to us um the the border
right now is wide open and the the
president um has finally I guess had a
conversation with the president of
Mexico to address the issue but when the
United States doesn't close the border
it's not up to the Mexican president to
tell its people to stop entering isn't
it our responsibility and what what is
this President
thinking well it's great to be on Julie
and you're exactly right I mean it's
nice that the president President Biden
is you know finally talking to the
president of Mexico but this should have
been happening a long time ago when his
own press secretary is going to the Mike
and saying you know oh there's uh
nothing new going on here uh that's
crazy I mean what's new here is we've
had record numbers this week uh we had
45,000 in apprehension since Monday
alone uh the extent to which this crisis
is now escalating beyond anything we've
ever seen before uh is something we can
now see with our own eyes and and shout
out to bill maluan for all of his
reporting you're right um he's been
shining a light on this for a long time
a lot of us have been saying this and
you all know this and I've been on the
show with Harris and others on Fox going
all the way back to my first year in
Congress in 2019 trying to point out
that when you're ignoring the
enforcement of our laws then you're
going to have this crisis continue to
grow we've been saying that and the
White House has ignored it intentionally
purposely and you heard the in the
interviews right what were they saying
they were
saying what is that I want to work you
know what God bless them I understand
that that is not what our laws allow our
laws are not for that our laws do not
allow parole and Asylum those are
supposed to be specific for cases of
actual persecution religious persecution
political persecution and the fact is
we've put a big neon sight on our border
saying come in and our poor border Pat
border patrol agents are overwhelmed and
Texans are dying six children in the
school district in which my family lives
died from fentanyl poisonings last year
is heartbreaking talking to the parents
we've got to stop it and Republicans
need to hold the line here against the
White House and I'm glad you said about
Mike Johnson he is correct we need to
hold the line we should not have a
single dollar going to Ukraine at all
until the southern border of the United
States is secure and importantly why
would we go fund the Department of
Homeland Security on February 2nd
without demanding changes from this
Administration Texas lieutenant governor
uh Dan Patrick with some pretty Choice
words for the president over the Border
crisis I want you to listen of
this everybody knows it this President
is cold-hearted he doesn't care about
what's happening to American citizens or
those coming here this is this is um
we're going to put them on planes we're
going to put them on trains we're going
to put them on buses we're going to do
whatever we can we're going to get them
out of Texas I want to send them all to
Martha's Vineyard I want to send them
all to Delaware and
raob okay so under title 42 when you
tried to cross the border you were sent
back okay under Biden's open border
policy you were allowed in and these
custom border patrol agents that we were
talking about it's literally 200
migrants to one that's how ridiculous it
is they're working the holiday rather
than booking people either containing
them or sending them back to their
country they're actually processing
paperwork in order for them to be bust
to Sanctuary cities here in the United
States I mean look at them climbing over
the barriers you know we've watched
thousands there's nobody there stopping
them they're just like welcome I'm
surprised that they're not holding
welcome signs like they do at the
airport when your loved ones touch down
but this is how easy it is for migrants
to come into the border now we've got an
election around the corner let's talk
about that because apparently supposedly
kamla Harris is going to start
campaigning uh in 2024 um and she's
going to start traveling across the
country when is she going to travel to
the Border that's where she needs to go
campaign yeah I mean her only trip to
the Border has been in a pit stop to go
to a fundraiser in California she
stopped in El Paso for a photo op the
president the vice president secretary
mycus totally Mia but let me go back Dan
Patrick is 100% right lieutenant
governor is completely correct we should
be shipping folks to other parts of the
country as Greg Abbott did that last
year uh my friend Governor Dan santis
send a Plane full of people who are here
illegally to Martha's Vineyard uh that
was important and you know on the
political Dynamic Republicans need to go
on offense on this because this is
something that is critical to our
national security and we can win on this
and it's something that not only can we
win politically we can win for the
American people if we'll stand up and
fight but it's going to take all of us
to go say we're going to hold the line
on funding of government and on Ukraine
to demand change out of this
administration because they're blatantly
ignoring the laws using Asylum and
parole to completely consume it we
passed hr2 and people throw that around
like oh that's a crazy bill you know
what you just talked about on title 42
that was a health code covid provision
we got hr29 my bill to say turnaway
authorities should be fully in place we
got that embedded into hr2 to give them
the power to turn away the White House
doesn't want to use it because they want
to dangerous and have open borders we
should stop that and stay with border
patrol and the American people all right
I've got a new information I want to
talk to you about uh regarding the
Congressional testimony of former
Delaware assistant us attorney Leslie
wolf uh House Republicans and IRS
whistleblowers accuse her of working to
limit questions about President Biden
now in her deposition to a house panel
last week she denied politics played any
role in the hunter Biden ad
investigation we'll see about that uh in
uh committee chair Jim Jordan and
frustrated obviously by the interview
let's
listen well M uh wolf refused to answer
most of our questions even um I mean we
had a number of exhibits where she's
sending the email she's receiving the
email she's and she refused to answer U
just about every question seemed we
had the New York Post reports wolf
testified 79 times that she was not
authorized by the doj to answer certain
questions about the case now when the
house returns from its holiday break it
will likely weigh contempt charges for
Hunter because you as you know you're on
the committee uh he denied a subpoena
for an interview so you can deny a
subpoena for an interview when if you're
innocent why would you do that and
second of all if you don't answer
questions how do you get answers it
seems dodging questions seems
politically motivated am I wrong here
yeah no you're exactly right I mean look
what the truth is pretty simple there 15
to $24 million that we know has flowed
from foreign sources and foreign
countries enemies you know like China
into the Biden family we know that okay
and that's the evidence we also know
that the president lied about knowing
about the business associations between
Hunter and the individuals involved and
now we're seeing the obstruction the
third prong of this where the doj is not
allowing us to get to the truth that's
why the impeachment inquiry was so
important just two weeks ago when we
voted to do that so we now have more
powers and now what you're seeing with
Leslie wolf is more of the same
obstruction more of the same refusal to
answer the questions they don't want to
answer the questions cuz they know the
truth the fact is they were slow walking
the investigation when we wanted to look
at Hunter Biden's tax returns in 2014
and 15 they let the statutes of
limitation run that means that they were
engaging in obstructing justice of us
trying to pursue the truth so so Jim
Jordan and Jamie comr are going to keep
doing the good work and we should hold
Hunter Biden in contempt he knows full
well he didn't want to come forward and
testify he wants to come forward and
plead the fifth he can do that but he
shouldn't thumb his nose at the hearing
he should have come forward and he
should have answered questions in a
deposition because he's got a lot of
explaining to do his father has a lot of
explaining to do I mean the left likes
to say that there's no evidence that his
father knew about his business dealing
and possibly even profited from business
dealings despite the fact that there is
a paper trail of millions of dollars
being funneled to the Biden family um
I'd like to hear from the president
himself um rather than hearing more
about how he supports his son uh it's
great that he's a doting loving father
but uh it looks like there's a lot more
here than that well and remember that
the doj the whistleblowers they tell us
that Leslie wolf was saying oh uh it was
politically motivated in October of 2020
that the doj didn't want to get in and
go pursue what we were looking into with
Hunter's uh laptop so we know that it
was politically motivated and doj is
refusing to let that evidence come to
light the American people deserve to
know the truth this isn't political this
isn't retribution this is about our
country and foreign actors sending
millions of dollars to influence the
vice president of the United States he
lied about it and then he's obstructing
us getting to the truth but this
shouldn't be a shiny object from us
doing the work of the American people to
secure the border and cut spending but
we should pursue the truth wherever it
may lead yeah yeah it's under there
somewhere but uh unfortunately it's
going to take longer because they're not
being very transparent about it uh
Congressman chip Roy thank you very much
for talking to us appreciate it and
Merry Christmas to you Merry Christmas
Julie thank you hey everyone I'm Emily
compano catch me and my co-hosts Harris
vulner and Kaylee mcken on outnumbered
every weekday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or
set your DVR also don't forget to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
for daily highlights